the white house strategy is not working
that statement could apply to
basically any area of public policy the
economy immigration crime education
certainly foreign policy but it is
especially true
of ukraine
which joe biden and company have botched
every single step of the way for years
going all the way back to the time that
joe biden was vice president and the
point man on ukraine so when kamala
harris was asked this week what the
biden administration planned to do
differently moving forward
you might have expected them to offer at
least i don't know one or two
suggestions
but you would be wrong
despite failure after failure after
catastrophic failure
the white house plans to change
nothing
so what else do we have to throw at this
when putin so far is undeterred
well we are gonna continue to do what
we've done
they're gonna they're gonna continue to
do what they've done exactly
what they are already
doing
which hasn't worked just like the last
time kamala was asked about changing a
failed strategy
at what point does the administration
say you know what this strategy isn't
working we're going to change strategies
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
inspiring it is time mr gorbachev tear
down this wall it is time we have
nothing to fear but fear itself it is
time
for us to be doing
what we have been doing and that time
is every day the white house remains
confident that in the long run
their strategy which has never worked
is going to work kamala harris is just
as confident today
of their strategy to stop the russian
war in ukraine as she was six weeks ago
that the war would never start in the
first place
i will repeat myself
and i'm vice president of the united
states and the president and i
work closely together and i know his
position because he has been consistent
in that regard
if vladimir putin and russia takes
aggressive action it will be met with a
cost that will be severe
it will of course it it wasn't it
happened it wasn't they have no
credibility but joe biden's been
consistent he has been consistent don't
worry it'll work this time the white
house strategy and the definition of
madness doing the same things over and
over and over again
and expecting different results i'm so
glad you liked that clip now please ring
the bell
subscribe
you you can get all the notifications
for our videos and then head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch your google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show
leave a five star review if you wouldn't
mind we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]